друзі термінові новини
Толік ширше і відправитися туди куди я
давно час у в'язницю фантастика наше хату
зараз повідомила про те, що він затриманий у
іспанії
звичайно затриманий іспанськими
правоохоронцями та за запитом
української сторони
спільно з офісом генпрокурора
давали туди ці запити дещиця
підозрюють за двома статтями
державна зрада та
розпалювання міжнаціональної ворожнечі не в
загалом для всіх абсолютно правильно в іспанії
за трибуна проросійського блогу рана
таліш арія нікого з дурниці дозрів тримаючи
заради прав на рівні органи іспанії за
3 мани і ось 4 трьома 2020 другу руку зі
столом очікуємо зодіаку this ній
взаємодієш би bespeco україни з
офісом генерального прокурора
міжнародними партнерами то в
результаті багата рима ви спецоперації
українських правоохоронців за три мани
хробаків і свічення ще шкірок з
рідних українців рано через від риму і
заслужене покарання та з юними два роди
нападаємо ще українська спецслужба ти
дози анатолію шарію овчини не закруту в
передачі 2mass Тетяна кримінального
кодексу України за статтю 111 отримавши
нас рада і стаття 161 порушення
рим спрямованості громадян закладений у
них расові та національні налагодженості
releasing пари кунай інвалідність це за
їм самого знаком толік дам зараз
намагався останнім часом робити вишень то
він нібито гуманітаркою якесь займався
та ще чимось насправді цей подонок
роками працював проти України та злу
правильно говорить в інформаційній сфері
на замовлення іноземних держав ми
знаємо це не держава одного
конкретного Російської Федерації толік
працював на росію роками і просувався
їх narrative та
затирав мізки мільйонам людей своїми
розповідями аріна почалося вторгнення він
говорив київ по у
зелені чоловічки висадилися вже в
урядовому кварталі
все вже сталося сил Росії ніяких
ракетних та авіаційних або
артилерійських ударів по містах України
не наносять повідомили у міністерстві
оборони Російської Федерації
високоточними засобами ураження
виводять з ладу військова інфраструктура
об'єкт та військовий аеродром та авіації
збройних сил України заявили
відомстві цивільного населення нічого
не загрожують
так сили днр завдають ударів по позиціях
на славу по всій лінії зіткнення
використовуючи всі доступні засоби
поразки басурин
грантх армія по суті паралізована зараз
зараз з того що я бачу я
бачу повний параліч взагалі і
держоргану та тих хто повинен був що там
але якимось чином допомагати мирному
носили коли нічого не трапилося він
почав розповідати що не давайте
україні зброя чим більше зброя тим
більше війни буде ось це все нісенітниця ще
все виконував замовлення російської
пропаганди всі друзі всі і тепер через
таких виродків я зараз миколаєву
про такі виродки людям миколаєве повітря
що там ми воду знову привезли люди
стоять з баклажками води не можуть навіть
отримати 21 столітті он черзі машину на
заправки тому що нічого ні води ні
бензину обстрілюють наші міста
знищують нас через такі виродки як
чи це які себе там щось ліпив
став свою партію проросійську мережам
його партія шер'ян скрізь підонки до
лаборанти які скрізь тільки проти
україни бігав там в одесі його підонок
збирала українські прапори
зі столів ось таких ось покидьків він
позбирав і привів до влади толік я
тобі казав що доведеться за все
відповідати я тобі у я писав запити на
частка в хату по до речі частина справ по
дещицю відкрито за моїм зверненням а і
нарешті справедливість дійшла до ще
займався окремо з маркою федін їм ми
займалися, щоб його позбавили статусу
біженця у литві і без цього рішення
взагалі не змогли затримати його позбавили
цього статусу біженців біженець сидів там
ввели багатомільйонну на березі і
середземного моря в каталонії біля
барселони дуже друзі це чудовий день
я всіх вас вітаю
ось так буде з кожним виродком і покидьком
тримаємо стрій друзі твій лик падла
отримав